that's not like a rhetorical question i
really don't know good morning hank it's
tuesday so in wonderful news the
anthropocene reviewed book is here it's
so beautiful
i'm so grateful to the people who made
this book there are so many wonderful
details like these are the end papers
they're based on my circle drawings and
then if you go to the end paper opposite
the signature page there's a review of
autographs and yes even my copy is
signed because there are no unsigned
copies i've got just a regular green
signature by the way but it's a
good-looking signature i mean i'd say
it's like a three and a half star
signature okay so writers are often told
to distill their work into an elevator
pitch like if you had a short elevator
ride with someone to tell them about
your book
what would you say and i think this is
always pretty hard because books usually
aren't about whatever they're about
right like turtles all the way down
isn't really about the disappearance of
a local billionaire it's about
mental illness and free will and how it
feels to have your consciousness
hijacked by intrusive thoughts
an absolutely remarkable thing isn't
really about its plot either this is
actually one of the things i wanted to
write about in the anthropocene reviewed
we want to
distill life down into single data
points or elevator pitches but the
reality of human experience is so
nuanced and multitudinous so what do i
say like here's my actual elevator pitch
being human in 2021
is very weird it's weird because we are
unprecedentedly powerful but can still
be brought to our knees by a strand of
rna
it's weird because we are like made out
of earth and it's weird because human
attention itself is weird how we pay
attention and what we pay attention to
ends up shaping the world we share in
ways we often don't pay attention to
so i tried to write a book about that
but if i say that people don't know the
premise of the book so maybe instead i
should say that the anthropocene
reviewed is a book of essays that take
the form of extremely in-depth
yelp reviews except instead of reviewing
like barber shops and restaurants i'm
reviewing
viral meningitis and this photograph and
the first five minutes of the movie
penguins of madagascar or maybe i should
just stick to explanatory facts like
it's my first book of nonfiction and
most of the reviews are adapted from a
podcast i write but some are new to the
book or maybe i should just quote the
blurbs like i can hardly do better than
my podcast hero anna sale of death sex
and money who said the anthropocene
reviewed somehow satisfies all the
contradictory demands i have for a book
right now
it stimulates my brain while getting me
out of my head while taking me to far
away places while grounding me in the
wonders of my
everyday that's lovely but i wonder if i
should also say that like the book is
intended to be a memoir it begins in my
childhood when i saw haley's comet and
smelled scratch and sniff stickers and
moves through my adolescence when i
became fascinated by the internet and
then through my 20s when i worked at a
children's hospital and survived a
mental health crisis and then
into adulthood and becoming a parent and
so in that sense it's a really personal
book but it's also about like canada
geese and the black death
and this particular kind of wintry
precipitation called gropple
i don't know what the book is about i
guess it's about whether e.e cummings
was right when he wrote that snow
doesn't give a soft white damn whom it
touches it's about how it feels to live
in what mary oliver called
this the one world we all belong to
where everything
sooner or later is part of everything
else it's about the terror of time
passing and
me with it it's about the silliness and
indispensability of the five star scale
and it's about how
this last year changed all the past ones
and
also all the future ones but that all
makes it sound quite serious when
hopefully it's often funny so yeah i
don't know if you've listened to the
podcast maybe you know what the book is
about and can tell me
in comments because i cannot seem to
figure out how to talk about it i do
know however that signed copies of the
anthropocene reviewed are available for
pre-order now and that grace han's cover
is so
so lovely all right i'm off to figure
out what the anthropocene review is
about and then pretend i knew all along
i will see you on friday